[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
termina la calma en haití la oposición y
el primer ministro habían logrado un
acuerdo para formar un gobierno de
unidad nacional y convocar a una
asamblea constituyente pero ahora ariel
enrique se convirtió en sospechoso del
asesinato del presidente jouvenel moix
en julio y el gobernador de california
gavin newsom sobrevivió a un referendo
revocatorio y seguirá en el cargo los
republicanos habían convocado a esa
consulta en su contra por su gestión de
la pandemia pero la campaña terminación
de un pulso entre conservadores y
progresistas
y ustedes saben que es un quilombo si no
sigan viendo aquí américa les cuento más
adelante
y vamos de inmediato a haití para
nuestra historia principal esta semana
el primer ministro ariel en ree
destituyó al fiscal general después de
que éste pidiera que se le imputara como
sospechoso del asesinato del presidente
juvenil moix en ri juró en el cargo tras
ese magnicidio y ahora es señalado por
haber hablado por teléfono dos veces con
un sospechoso clave la noche del
asesinato
y es legal él es el primer ministro de
haití ariel en ree ex ministro del
trabajo neuropatólogo ahora sospechoso
del asesinato del presidente lleven el
móvil
el martes el fiscal general de haití
recomendó investigar a enric por el
asesinato de moix en reír respondió
despidiendo al fiscal general y
nombrando a un nuevo ministro de
justicia el primer ministro defendió su
inocencia
las acciones para crear confusión y
desviar a la justicia no van a ser
toleradas a dar paso a los verdaderos
cabecillas de cerebros' los responsables
del asesinato de joven el moi se
enfrentarán a la justicia y serán
castigados por sus actos movice fue
asesinado el 7 de julio cuando un grupo
de mercenarios haciéndose pasar por
agentes de la agencia antidrogas de eeuu
irrumpieron en su vivienda
y decenas fueron arrestados entre ellos
18 militares retirados colombianos y dos
haitianos estadounidenses pero muchos
sospechosos clave siguen a la fuga
incluyendo un ex empleado de la unidad
anticorrupción del ministerio de
justicia a quien moix ha defendido
públicamente
el destituido fiscal dice que el primer
ministro habló con el sospechoso dos
veces por teléfono en la noche del
asesinato de moix henry asegura que se
trata de un teatro y solo el presidente
del país tiene la autoridad para obligar
al primer ministro a someterse a una
investigación la constitución también
estipula que los fiscales sólo pueden
ser despedidos o nombrados por el
mandatario pero el cargo está vacante
desde el magnicidio
vamos a eeuu para revisar la imagen de
la semana eles gavin newsom el
gobernador de california que supera una
campaña republicana para retirarlo del
cargo el demócrata obtuvo un amplio
margen de votos que le permitió dejar
atrás a sus competidores entre los que
estaba kaitlyn tener la victoria muestra
que los californianos siguen apoyando a
newsom pero es un llamado de atención
para los demócratas en un estado que
tradicionalmente los vota en las
presidenciales revisemos cómo funciona
este mecanismo revocatorio en eeuu
gavin newsom ahora tiene un respiro con
cerca del 70 de los votos contados
aventaja por mucho a sus rivales
republicanos
en la espalda make le dijimos si a
terminar la pandemia al derecho a votar
sin miedo y sin falsos fraudes o
supresión de voto are water prize y luís
arias le dijimos si el derecho
constitucional de la mujer a decidir por
sí misma por south
los republicanos habían convocado el
referendo revocatorio citando el manejo
de la pandemia del gobernador demócrata
pero el diverso grupo de rivales
conservadores que incluían a la estrella
de televisión cave línea nerd y al
anfitrión radial largo y helder perdiera
a mi oponente el gobernador gavin newsom
como an
primamos aceptemos con decoro la derrota
[Aplausos]
en web
we may por cierto puede que hayamos
perdido la batalla pero ganaremos
windows
el mecanismo de revocatoria del estado
permite convocar elecciones haciendo una
petición así fue como el actor de
hollywood el republicano arnold
schwarzenegger llegó a ser gobernador en
históricamente california ha votado por
los candidatos demócratas a la
presidencia pero la revocatoria es un
llamado de atención para este partido
presidente joe biden respaldó el
gobernador al final de la campaña el
referendo revocatorio llegó cuando ambos
partidos se encaminan a las elecciones
de medio término de 2022 que
determinarán quién controla el congreso
y seguimos hablando de elecciones
argentinas celebro las primarias que
definen quienes van a las legislativas
de noviembre pero esta vez terminaron
siendo casi un referendo de la gestión
del presidente alberto fernández y su
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner pues sus candidatos perdieron
la mayoría de los distritos del país
la derrota produjo una pelea abierta
entre ambos cinco ministros y altos
cargos que representaban a la
vicepresidenta en el gobierno
renunciaron y el presidente tuvo que
decir en redes sociales que es él el que
toma las decisiones
nombrado vamos a perú para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana la
polémica por el destino de los restos
fúnebres del fundador del grupo
terrorista sendero luminoso terminó con
la decisión del congreso de que sea
incinerado y que sea el ministerio de
justicia el que disponga donde dispersar
sus restos
abimael guzmán falleció en prisión
mientras cumplía varias condenas entre
ellas una por violaciones a los derechos
humanos y su esposa también en prisión
había pedido que se le entregara a ella
su cuerpo lo que las autoridades negaron
para evitar que donde se sepulte se
convierta en un lugar de culto y las
celebraciones del bicentenario en el
salvador estuvieron marcadas por
protestas en contra del presidente nayib
bukele los ciudadanos salieron a las
calles en rechazo a la denominación del
bitcoin como moneda oficial en la nación
centroamericana que en su primera semana
ya superó los 500 mil usuarios en el
monedero chivo y méxico también
conmemoró su independencia el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador dio el
tradicional grito en el zócalo pero sin
público por segundo año consecutivo
debido a la pandemia del cob y 19 en el
desfile militar estuvo el presidente de
cuba miguel díaz-canel como invitado de
honor el mexicano pidió a eeuu que
levante el embargo económico a la isla
y ustedes saben que es un quilombo a lo
mejor están familiarizados con el uso de
la palabra en argentina una situación
caótica pero no se trata de comunidades
fundadas por africanos esclavizados en
brásil que lograron escapar durante los
tiempos coloniales sus descendientes
siguen preservando su cultura y sus
tradiciones incluso hoy en los últimos
años el quilombo kalunga el más grande
del país ha sido abandonado por el
gobierno pero gracias a la resiliencia
de esta comunidad que a pesar de ser
víctima de racismo empezó a trabajar
para atraer el turismo las cosas están
mejorando nuestro equipo en brasil viajó
hasta el quilombo kalunga y nos preparó
el siguiente reportaje
en el corazón de la sabana brasileña
entre las montañas que alguna vez
protegieron a los esclavistas está este
remoto quilombo el de las comunidades
calonga
adriano que creció en esta tierra árida
y polvorienta quiere compartir los
tesoros escondidos de su gente
bienvenidos soy su guía estoy aquí para
mostrarles la belleza y la historia del
quilombo que ha existido hace más de 370
años en 2008 los habitantes de este
quilombo que durante años fueron
víctimas de racismo y discriminación
empezaron a improvisar como guías desde
entonces más de 100 mil turistas han
llegado a la zona lo que ha creado
nuevos empleos como el de adriano quien
solía trabajar en granjas vecinas por
mucho menos dinero solía trabajar en los
campos de otras personas para reunir
dinero para ayudar a mi familia ahora
trabajo en el campo de mi familia cerca
a la naturaleza a las cascadas después
de trabajar tienes tiempo para hacer
otras cosas mientras conservas tu
cultura santa barbara es una de las
cascadas más famosas en la región
después del cierre obligado por la
pandemia reabrió recientemente a los
turistas este lugar solía atraer
alrededor de 7000 personas al año pero
ahora sólo unas pocas decenas de
visitantes privilegiados pueden
disfrutar de sus aguas cristalinas un
baño revitalizante el agua está helada
pero el lugar es hermoso
al principio venimos para descubrir esta
cascada pero gracias a nuestro guía ya
nuestro contacto con la comunidad
aprendimos mucho especialmente de la
historia de brasil y los alumnos
aquí cada turista paga alrededor de 50
dólares que van directamente a las
comunidades este dinero aunque poco
ayuda a los kalunga a hacer mejoras
natalia quien empezó este pequeño
proyecto ha logrado construir salones de
clases una clínica y otros proyectos de
infraestructura que deberían ser
financiados por el gobierno
fue un trabajo este es un tanque de agua
es gracias al dinero de los turistas que
vienen aquí a disfrutar de las cascadas
que podemos pagarlo el agua es
extremadamente importante para nosotros
porque nos permite vivir más cerca como
comunidad esta reserva trae agua
alrededor de 700 personas el preciado
territorio de los kalunga está siendo
destruido por los cultivos de soya el
año pasado más de 1000 hectáreas de
terrenos de la comunidad fueron
ilegalmente invadidos y destruidos por
el sector agrícola
y me despido en nueva york'
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tras 18 meses de cierre debido a la
pandemia de kobe 19 el teatro musical
regresó a broadway grandes éxitos como
'el rey león' y hamilton volvieron a
manhattan pero los asistentes debían
demostrar una prueba de vacunación y
portar la mascarilla gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa soy natalia cabrera pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo el giovanni algo de lo
sigan viendo más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Aplausos]
[Música]